[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم كشفت اذا مصادر
في حركه احرار الشام السوريه المعارضه
كشفت عن اتفاق مبدئي لوقف اطلاق النار
لمده يومين فيز اني بريف دمشق وفوعه
وكفريا بريف ادلب وياتي هذا الاتفاق حسب
مصادر في الحركه بعد مفاوضات بين ممثلها
ووفد ايراني نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما دلاله عوده الوفد الايراني
للتفاوض بخصوص الزبداني وما سر تمسك
النظام السوري وحزب الله بالزبداني
وما مدى منطقيه الشروط التي يطرحها الجان
الايراني المنخرط في مفاوضات الزبداني
للتوصل الى اتفاق
[موسيقى]
بشانه بعد مقتل خمسه من مسلحي حزب الله
اللبناني في زبدان خلال يوم واحد وللمره
الثالثه حسب ما هو معلن خلال شهر يعود
التفاوض بشان الزبداني بين حركه احرار
الشام التي كانت على الدوام المصدر المباد
بالكشف عن هذه المفاوضات وبين وفد ايراني
تقول الحركه انه يفاوض انابه او نيابه عن
النظام السوري وحسب مصادر احرار الشام فان
اصرار الوفد الايراني على اخلاء الزبداني
من المدنيين كان على الدوام سببا في نهايه
المفاوضات السابقه التي ناقشت ايضا حسم
مصير مصير قريتي الفوعه وكفريا الشيعيين
في ريف ادلب نتابع في البدايه تقرير مريم
ابيش اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار في الزبداني
والفوعة
وقف اطلاق النار المؤقت يشمل الزبداني
الواقعه في ريف دمشق والمحاصر من قوات حزب
الله والنظام السوري منذ فتره وهي خاضعه
لسيطره المعارضه ومدينه انقاض بسبب القتال
الذي نشب منذ نحو شهرين وفق بعض المصادر
يوجد فيها نحو 1500 مسلح من المعارضه يشمل
الاتفاق ايضا قريتي الفوعه وكفريا بريف
ادلب تخضع القريتين لسيطره الجيش النظامي
وعناصر من الحرس الثوري الايراني ولكنهما
محاصران من قبل مسلحي المعارضه فشلت
المفاوضات اكثر من مره بسبب طلب ايران
تغيير ديمغرافيا المناطق المتفاوض عليها
يفترض ان تسمح الهدنه الحاليه باجراء
مفاوضات اوسع اوسع تعني ربما الاتفاق على
اخراج جميع سكان الزبداني وهم من السنه
وتهجير جميع الشيعه من كفريه وفوعه
استنادا لبعض المصادر يوجد عدد كبير من
المسلحين الايرانيين في تين القريتين بريف
ادلب جولات المفاوضات كشفت ان من يدير
الحرب ويتفاوض من اجل الهدن المؤقته ليس
جيش النظام السوري وانما دوله اجنبيه وحزب
من دوله جاره ثم لماذا تطرح مساله تهجير
المدنيين من مناطقهم بسبب انتمائهم
الطائفي اهي بدايه تقسيم سوريا تدريجيا
يفترض ان تسمح الهدنه المعلنه باخراج
الجرحى في المرحله الاولى هذا طبعا اذا لم
يحدث خرق لوقف اطلاق النار والجرح الاكبر
وفق البعض هو استمرار حرب جغرافيا تدور في
سوريا ولكن من يخوضها ليسوا كلهم من اهل
البلد ماذا بقي من نظام احرقت البلد من
اجله وهو اليوم تحت حمايه ورحمه ايران
وحزب الله
اللبناني موضوع حلقتنا هذا اذا نناقشه مع
ضيفين من فين مصطفى علوش عضو المكتب
السياسي لتيار المستقبل اللبناني و من
طهران حسين روران الباحث المتخصص في
الشؤون الاقليميه نرحب بضيفي من طهران
وفينا وابدا معك سيد حسين في طهران نريد
ان نفهم في البدايه ما دلاله عوده الوفد
الايراني للتفاوض بشان الزبداني وما سر
تمسك النظام السوري وحزب الله بالزبداني
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اي يعني اولا هي
ليست هناك من
اخبار رسميه من قبل الحكومه الايرانيه حول
هذا الموضوع وكل ما يطرح هو من مصادر
اجنبيه هذا اولا ثانيا اتصور ان هذا الدور
الذي تقوم به ايران هو
لوقف
القتال واساله الدماء في سوريا واتصور ان
هذا متطابق مع الموقف السياسي ير
الذي يؤكد على وقف اطلاق النار في كل
المحاور ثانيا ثالثا يعني الزبداني
بالنهايه هي منطقه قريبه جدا من
دمشق تلعب د سيد حسين فرق بين ان تلعب
ايران دور الوسيط في المفاوضات او ان
تتولى كما تفعل هذه المره في زبداني ان
تتولى هي عمليه التفاوض بنفسها من خلال
وجود وفد ايراني يقوم بالتفاوض
يعني انا في تصوري ان ايران هي ليست
طرفا في هذه الحرب واضح يعني ان القوات
السوريه وحزب الله هم الذين يقاتلون في
الزبداني ايران ليست لها قوات هناك ولكن
ايران تحاول ان تلعب دور الوسيط في هذا
الاطار لان هناك الابرياء موجودون في كل
الجبهات وليس في هذه الجبهه فقط واتصور ان
موقع الزبداني القريب من دمشق هو موقع
اساسي بالنسبه للنظام من هنا ايجاد حل
للازمه في الزبداني هو لصالح النظام وكذلك
لصالح القوات المحاصره التي يمكن ان تقتل
فيما اذا استمر القتال وهي الان موجوده في
ما يقار كيف يمكن فهم اصرار ايران على
تولي ملف التفاوض بخصوص زبداني وقريتي
الفوع وكفريا ان تتولى هي بنفسها من خلال
وفد ايراني عمليه
المفاوضات يعني الموقف الرسمي الايراني هو
دائما موقف التجاهل ال المضحك لانه عمليا
لا يمكن لاي عاقل ان يقبل بالحديث بان
ايران هي وسيط بين المعارضه وبين
المقاتلين ضد النظام و مع النظام عمليا
منذ سنوات وربما منذ سنه 2005 اصبحت عمليا
سوريا تحت مستعمره ايرانيه وهناك الدلائل
الكثيره على هذا الموضوع من الناحيه
الاجتماعيه العسكريه الماليه السياسيه وكل
ما هنالك ولكن بالتاكيد
منذ ان تطورت الثوره في سوريا الى مراحل
متقدمه اصبحت ايران هي عمليا القائد
الفعلي لكل المواقع ولكل شيء وعندما تاتي
ايران للت تفاوض هذا يعني لانها هي
المعنيه بالامور اما النظام فبالنسبه له
يريد ان يحفظ وجوده لا اكثر ولا اقل لكن
لماذا يتمسك النظام وحزب الله بالزبداني
يعني من يتمسك بالزبداني هو حزب الله
النظام لو اتت الى النظام ف خياراته اصبحت
معروفه وهي بالنهايه ان يذهب الى ما يسمى
بعلى وستان او الساحل اما بالنسبه لمنطقه
الزبد بالذات فهي عمليا اخر تواصل يعني هي
المنطقه التي تفصل بين الحدود اللبنانيه
وال والحدود السوريه وعمليا اذا اكملت
المعارضه السوريه انطلاقها من الجنوب
باتجاه الوسط ف ووصلت الى الزبداني يعني
ان منطقه القلمون من جديد اصبحت ساقطه
وعادت الحدود اللبنانيه السوريه يعني
تواصل حزب الله مع
سوريا يصبح شبه مقطوع وتصبح المناطق من
جديد
مسرحا للقتال يعني عمليا ما يريده حزب
الله هو المحافظه على الخط من دمشق باتجاه
ال حمص ومن حمص باتجاه الساحل السوري على
امل ان يفرض وقائع ثابته في حال حصل تفاوض
على وضع نهائي بالنسبه لسوريا لذلك القضيه
هي قضيه تتعلق بحزب الله لا تتعلق بما
تبقى بالنظام السوري حتى اتباع النظام
السوري الان في سوريا يؤكدون بان سوريا
الان هي بيد ايران وان المزيد من القتلى
والمزيد من الدمار هو بسبب قضيه تتعلق
بايران اكثر ما تتعلق
ب الشعب السوري نعم لكن والسؤال للاستاذ
حسين روران لكن هناك يعني مناطق واسعه
ايضا ما زالت او باتت خارج سيطره النظام
وحلف
فائه هل ما سر هذه الاستماته برايك من
جانب النظام ومن جانب حزب الله في الدفاع
ومحاوله السيطره على زبداني سلما او
حربا يعني اولا الزبداني هي منطقه حدوديه
محاذ لسوريا اولا قريبه من دمشق ثانيا
وامكانيه الحسم فيها قائم
من هنا يعني
اي العمليات جاريه ضمن اطار هذا المنطق في
تصوري واتصور ان يعني لحد الان الحكومه
السوريه الجيش السوري وحزب الله استطاع ان
يحصر المقاتلين ضمن اطار مربع هو لا يزيد
عن كيلومتر او كيلومترين مربعين في
الزبداني ومن هنا في هذه المعادله هم هم
يمتلكون اليد العليا
في الزبداني ويحاولان ان يفرض شروطهما على
احرار الشام التيار الاقوى وا الموجود في
هذه المنطقه ا سيد علوش يعني اذا كانت
اليد العليا للنظام السوري ول حزب الله
وبالتالي هم خلينا نقول الاكثر قدره على
استعمال هذه الورقه كشروط تفاوض كي الى اي
يعني هذا التفاوض بهذه الشروط الى اين
يمكن ان
يؤدي السؤال هو سؤال منطقي والجواب بطبيعه
الحال اذا كانت
حرب حياه او موت بالنسبه لحزب الله
والنظام او ما تبقى من نظام بشار الاسد
وايضا بالنسبه للمعارضه عمليا ليس من
المنطق ان
تذهب ايران الى التفاوض بهذا الخ فلتقم
يعني فليقم حزب الله بما يعتقد بانه واجبه
ولكن هناك ورقتين
اساسيتين بطبيعه الحال اليد العليا هي ل
بسبب الحشود وبسبب الحصار ولكن هناك ايضا
ورقه اخرى وهي القريتين المحاصرتين ايضا
من جهه
المعارضه نعم بالتاكيد وايضا عدد القتلى
الذي يسقط يعني هناك حرب استنزاف حقيقيه
بالنسبه ان كان لما تبقى من من يؤيد حافظ
بشار الاسد وان كان لحزب الله وهم يعني
ليسوا قادرين على تحمل المزيد من القتلى
هناك المئات حتى الان سقطوا في معركه
اعتقدوا بانها كشرب الماء ولكنها يبدو
تشبه وضع ستالينغراد ايام الحصار النازي
يعني هناك جيش نازي يحاصر الان
ا الزبداني وهناك كمقاوم وهذه المقاومه
ايضا اثبتت بانها تستميت دفاعا عن حقها
بان تكون على ارضها وضد قوه غاشمه وضد قوه
احتلال يعني حسب الله هو قوه احتلال بكل
معنى الكلمه لذلك ما يحاولون الان هو حصر
الخسائر وايضا حمايه القرى او او السكان
يعني حمايه العنصر وللاسف هنا نتحدث عن
حمايه عنصر شيعي بمجرد ان يكون هناك عنصر
شيعي في قريه ما يعتبر ب انه من ضمن
الممتلكات الايرانيه في المنطقه ا وهذا ما
يطرح كشرط ربما
لتبادل القريتين بالزبداني سنتحدث عن هذا
ولكن بعد ان ناخذ فاصلا قصيرا نعود بعده
لاستكمال النقاش في هذه النقاط المطروحه
في حلقتنا اليوم فلا تذهبوا
[موسيقى]
بعيدا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تتناول اتفاق الهدنه المؤقته في
الزبداني ومدى منطقيه الشروط المطروحه
للتوصل الى اتفاق نهائي بشان الزبداني
نرحب بكم و بضيفي من جديد في هذا الجزء
الثاني من البرنامج ونتحول الى الاستاذ
حسين في طهران سيد حسين يعني هذه الشروط
التي تطرحها ويطرحها الجانب الايراني
المنخرط في مفاوضات ال الزبداني هل تبدو
لك منطقيه مثلا مثل موضوع افراغ الزبداني
من سكانها من المدنيين وهو ما تقوله احرار
او يقوله احرار الشام ولم ينفى من الطرف
الاخر حتى
الان يعني اولا اتصور اننا نمتلك روايه
طرف وليس روايه طرفين يعني اولا ان تطالب
ايران بافراغ الزبداني لا اتصور انه منطقي
ولا اتصور ان ايران يمكن ان تطرح
هكذا مساله الزبداني الان هي منطقه قتال
ليس هناك
من نعم ولكن هذه الروايه سيد حسين مر
عليها الان تقريبا 20 يوم ولم يتم
نفيها لا بشكل رسمي ولا غير رسمي وهذه
الروايه قدمتها او قدمها احرار الشام منذ
20 يوما لكن لم تنفى حتى او لم يتم نفيها
حتى
الان
صحيح يعني عدم النفي لا يعني الاثبات
بالضروره من هنا انا اتصور ان يعني في
الزبداني هناك قتال بين مقاتلين في كفريا
والفوعة
لكون لكون سكان الزبداني مدنيين من السنه
ايضا
الزبداني
تفضل صحيح هذا الكلام ولكن الزبداني هي في
الاساس افرغت من اهاليها المدنيين بسبب
القتال قبل ذلك في حين ان الفع وكفريا هم
محاصران ليسوا من الان بل منذ سنتان او
ثلاث سنوات من هنا حل هذه الازمه اتصور
انها يمكن ان تشك هدفا نبيلا لكل الاطراف
رغم ان الظروف التي استوجبت الحرب هي ظروف
قاسيه وقد تكون في الكثير من المراحل هي
غير انسانيه استاذ علوش يعني هذا الحديث
عن تفريغ او افراغ الزبداني كان في الواقع
مثار ادانه واستهجان من عدد من الاطراف
لعل ابرزها بيان المثقفين العلويين
والشيعه في سوريا ولبنان الاسبوع الماضي
والذي حذر مما
سماها محاولات ايران لتقسيم سوريا على
اساس طائفي هل ترى فعلا موضوع الفرز
الطائفي والتقسيم الذي قد يذهب بسوريا الى
التقسيم ويبدا من الزبداني هل هو مطروح
هكذا كما
يصور يعني ال الواقع هناك مسائل معقده في
هذه القضيه ا وانا ارفض بنفس القدر الذي
ارفض به ان تحاصر قرى فقط لانتمائها
الديني ولكن نعلم بان هناك قوى ل ما تبقى
من النظام السوري والحرس الثوري نعلم
بانها في القرى الشيعيه ولكن مع ذلك ارفض
هذا المنطق بنفس الوقت منطق عندما ياتي
ويقول النظام او يقول النظام الايراني
بانه يريد ان يجري تبادل فهذا يعني اولا
بانهم يئسوا تماما من الاعاده ا السل سلطه
هذا النظام على الاراضي السوريه يعني هناك
حل سوف ياتي على اساس
واقع مواقع جديده وربما ما يحاول ان يفعله
الان حزب الله وعلى الارجح هذا ما يفعله
هو تثبيت هذه المواقع في
سبيل التفاوض المفاوضات لاحقا لكن بنفس
الوقت هناك ايضا حتى في المناطق
التي يمكن ان تسمى على وستان ويمكن ان
تسمى ايضا ما ما تبقى من المناطق الت
يسيطر عليها بشار الاسد والحرس الثوري حزب
الله هناك لا تزال اكثريه سنيه يعني
اكثريه السكان في هذه المناطق هم ايضا سنه
ولكن يعتبرون بانهم من غير المقاتلين او
من
غير الذين قد يتحولوا الى مقاتلين في وقت
من الاوقات لذلك القضيه هي هنا ابناء
الزبداني وابناء هذه المنطقه ابناء منطقه
القلمون
غطه الشرقيه اسبت والغط الغربيه بالتاكيد
ولكن الشرقيه الان هم اثبتوا بانهم
مقاتلين شرسين وبانهم ا قادر قادرون على
القيام بالمواجهه لذلك هناك حرب اباده
حقيقيه على هذه المنطقه كما يحدث الان في
دوما يعني لا يمكن تصوير ما يحدث في دوما
ذات ال 220,000 نسمه الا انها حرب اباده
عمليا نعم هناك حرب اباده على من يمكن ان
يقاتلوا النظام اما الباقين يعتبرون اتباع
ويمكن تقبلهم في اي تسويه استاذ حسين
روران يعني هذه الاتهامات بالفرز
الطائفي في سوريا في الواقع ليست ابتداع
او اختراعا او اكتشافا الجميع يتابع هذا
الموضوع عن كثب وبيان المثقفين الشيعه
والعلويين يتحدث عن هذا الامر ما الذي
يسوغ لايران برايك الحديث باسم سوريا باسم
الشعب السوري اي والتفاوض بدل سوريا اي
الا الا ينظر اليها في هذه الحاله على
انها قوه احتلال تفرض نفسها وتتفاوض باسم
دوله اخرى وشعب
اخر يعني اولا دخول ايران على خط
المفاوضات هو جاء بطلب من احرار الشام
وليس بطلب ايراني هذا للعلم ثانيا يعني
اولا تصوير المساله بهذا الشكل قد لا يكون
صحيحا ليس هناك من فائض بشري شيعي يمكن
يعني نقله من مكان الى مكان الشيعه في
سوريا لا يشكلون الا 2% من مجموع عدد
السكان
ثالثا يعني ليس هناك من امكانيه لفعل هذا
العمل واتصور انه خطير جدا يعني الكثير
طرح هذا الموضوع عندما تم تحرير حمص هل
تغيرت الديموغرافيه لا لم تتغير
يعني هذه تصورات تطرح للاستهلاك السياسي
وبعيده جدا عن الواقع كيف يمكن للشيعه من
الفوعه وكفريا ان يتركوا ارضهم وان
يتواجدوا في ارض يعني ارض غيرهم او بيوت
غيرهم يعني هذه المساله اتصور
انها بعيده عن العقل وهي نتاج
تصورات بعيده جدا عن الواقع ا طيب سيد
علوش وان كنا قد تحدثنا في البدايه عن
اهميه الزبداني لكنها نقطه ربما تساعدنا
على فهم المساله اكثر هذه الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه لمنطقه الزبداني في خطط
النظام السوري وحلفائه حزب الله
وايران هل تبرر لايران التدخل في ملف
التفاوض بخصوص
الزبداني سيدتي ال ما تبقى من نظام بشاص
خاصه فيما يتعلق سييد علوش خاصه فيما
يتعلق باخراج سكانها المدنيين السنه في
زبداني يعني ما تبقى من نظام بشار الاسد
هو اصبح تفصيل هامشي الواقع بان ايران هي
المسؤوله عن كل شيء الان في القياده
السياسيه والعسكريه والامنيه والاقتصاديه
والى كل ما هنالك ما يحدث الان هو لمصلحه
او محاوله لتصليب عود حزب الله وحمايه
المناطق التي يتواجد فيها حزب الله في
الداخل اللبناني وامتدادا الى المناطق
الاخرى لاستمرار التواصل في المستقبل
عندما سيكون هناك حلولا ما
ل للمساله السوريه لا يوجد قرار لا لا
يوجد شيء للتفاوض عليه لا يوجد احد ليفاوض
ضمن النظام السوري هناك تسليم كامل ل
للاداره الامور لايران وهاه هذا هو الواقع
المؤسف هو وال مبكي ايضا هو ان الحديث
مثلا عن حمص بانه لم يتغير هناك بعد
تحريرها بين هلالين لم يتغير شيء
ديمغرافيا ماذا ماذا حدث هناك 10 ملايين
سوري خرجوا من مناطقهم ان كان الى خارج
سوريا وان كان داخل سوريا من اين اتوا
هؤلاء هل اتوا من الصحراء او اتوا من
مناطق اتوا من حمص ومن دمشق ومن المناطق
التي تم الاعتداء عليها وتم احتلالها على
مدى الاربع السنوات الماضيه والحقيقه ان
ما يحدث في الزبداني نعم هذه الماسات كما
تصفها ما يحدث في الزبداني يذكرنا والسؤال
للسيد حسين
روان يذكرنا بما حدث في القصير التي منع
سكانها من السنه من العوده اليها حتى الان
لماذا
نستبعد ما يثار حول الزبداني اذا كان هذا
الوضع في القص صير سيد
حسين لا يعني عوده البدنيين هي قائمه في
هذه المناطق الحكومه اعلنت
والكثير من الصور ايضا عرضت
عوده المدنيين الى هذه المناطق نعم هناك
عوده عدم يعني عوده
المقاتلين المدنيون ل يعودوا الى القصير
سيد
حسين لا لا في القصير وغير القصير في كل
المناطق المحرره هناك عوده
ل اهالي هذه المناطق ويعني عدم العوده هي
هي غير صحيحه يعني انا اتذكر انني رايت
يعني حتى الصور التي عرضت في عوده الاهالي
الى مدينه القصير نعم طبعا نتحدث عن
السكان السنه لكن ادركنا وقت نهايه
البرنامج
بهذا ننهي هذه الحلقه كنا نود ان نحاول
سؤال الاخير للسيد علوش ولكن انتهى وقت
البرنامج بهذا اذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا
اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء
ه